now the approximation is greater than
what we found before which was 8 and 2/3
why is that can someone remind me why is
our approximation larger than the actual
answer can anyone tell me might help if
you go back to this diagram here
yep yeah very good perfect
okay so moany like you said there is
this missing sliver which I am I had
highlighted before but I deleted it so
that parts missing
and yes the trapezium is above the curve
now I'm not going to work through a full
example here but I hope you can
understand that in some cases it will be
exactly the opposite the trapezium will
not overestimate the area it will
underestimate the area now I wonder if
you can think about a situation in which
that would occur what kind of function
would the trapezium underestimate the
area instead of overestimating at the
area which is what happened here
okay I wonder if you can maybe do a
scribble on your piece of paper here if
I just draw a curve like this y equals x
squared we start there on the right hand
side if I drew a curve like this okay if
I did this guy and I was interested
saying the area under this part of the
curve right have a look at this if I
draw the trapezium by draining the tops
of those two green lines then you can
see the Tralee that's all right
it really depends on where right so if I
draw this guy here
there's the trapezium and clearly it's
actually less than what the actual area
is so if you go ahead and you use this
trapezium method you would get a result
that was less than the area not more
okay we're all proud of you sasha is
correct all right so what we've got here
we've got an area of ten we can see it's
an approximation but I kind of think
that we're really far off right like
we're one and a third units off that's
like a I don't know a twelve fifteen
percent error that's pretty bad right so
can we make this any better can we make
it any more accurate and the answer is
yes you can now max to your question in
the exam would they tell you to use this
method the answer is yes yes they
absolutely would in fact
even use language like use the
trapezoidal rule to approximate the area
underneath this curve and they'll be
even more specific than that
which I'll get to a bit later on so
let's have a look at this same graph
here it is y equals x squared again how
can I use the same technique to get a
more accurate result have a think and I
want you to remember back to the start
of a lesson remember I showed you this
this is from earlier on right if I put
in more rectangles that are thinner you
get a more accurate result right because
there's less of those as as moist called
them less of those slivers or the
slivers are smaller right actually
there's more slivers but the slivers are
very tiny so I can use the same
technique here Fiona Hamzah I'm you're
exactly right I'm gonna use more
trapezium is right it's like okay let's
just throw more threw more maths at it
right so I'm gonna take this same guy
here and instead of dividing it into a
or you know approximating it with a
single trapezium I'm gonna approximate
it with two trapeziums okay what are we
gonna get well if I slice it right down
the middle like so and then I've got the
same vertical lines that I had before
okay
what I can do is and you'll see it's
gonna get pretty close right I can draw
a line that's straight here and that
will give me one trapezium on the right
and then I can draw another one over
here which will give the trapezium on
the left so I'm going to have two
trapeziums that will approximate this
area now because they're the same kind
of shape I can use the same kind of
technique you just have to be a little
more careful okay for starters let's go
back to that area formula of a trapezium
right the area is the hyper
perpendicular height and then you needed
the two parallel sides right that's if
we were dealing with one trapezium but
now we've got two so how do I you know
adjust this formula so that I can use it
for this particular kind of arm setup
where there's more than one trapezium
well each trapezium will have its own
height you can see here there's a height
here and it's identical to this height
over here now
was our height before it was too right
now I've divided it into two equal
trapeziums or two trapeziums with equal
height I should say so what will each
height be it's not rocket science
go ahead and type it in the chat so I
know that you're actually paying
attention fantastic okay yes we're
getting there
thank you thank you thank you yes
exactly right so Ellie you've identified
they're both separate but they are equal
I've kind of divided it exactly down the
middle so I've got one and then I've got
one okay now I've got my height and I've
set up this this sort of arrangement so
they're the same but now I need my
parallel sides right and this time I
don't just have two parallel sides y1
and y2 write y1 and y2 we'll just deal
with the first trapezium I'm gonna call
this one y1 and I'm gonna make Y to the
one in the middle so that I can go in
order now I've got ya mo you well done
I've got a wife three okay so what's
gonna happen here well I need a few more
what we call function values that's
actually the name of these y1 y2 and y3
we call them function values and the
reason for that is because we we get
them we evaluate them by substituting
into the function okay now what we can
do is we can evaluate each of these
function values the way we did before we
already have the bottom one it's one we
already have the last one it's nine
what's the middle one
what's y2 can we square numbers team
going you talk we can do this maybe
you're catching up with your writing
that's okay fantastic yeah maybe it's my
internet connection all right so there's
my middle function value it's going to
be four now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to say this is still an
approximation right I'm approximating a
curvy thing with a straight line or
multiple straight lines but I'm gonna
get a better approximation right let's
have a go at this I'm gonna write
whoopsie-daisy area and to distinguish
it from the previous one I'm just gonna
write I'm just going to call this area
to okay again it's still approximate but
now I'm going to work out each of the
two
trapeziums right so it's H over 2 which
is 1 over 2 and then I'm going to have
in fact I'm going to write that as H
over 2 just so that we can see the next
line I'm gonna have y1 plus y2 that'll
deal with the first trapezium and then I
deal with the second trapezium same
height but it's parallel sides will not
be y1 y2 they'll be y2 and y3 okay
now I can do all the substitutions here
right we're going to return to this
later on but I can write this as 1 over
2 1 plus 4 and then it's 1 over 2 again
4 plus 9
let's go ahead and simplify I'm going to
get 5 on this one and I'm going to get
13 on the other one so that gives me 5
on 2 plus 13 on 2 that gives me 18 on 2
which is lime okay so what have we just
seen well by using more trapeziums I can
get a more accurate result and this is
much closer right think back to our
original integral we know the area is
exactly 8 and 2/3 we tried this first
way with one trapezium we got 10 I mean
at least we're in the right ballpark
where we could do better and we did by
putting in more trapeziums we got a more
accurate result
we're only within 1/3 of the actual area